people of all backgrounds will celebrate
and defend our most precious gift life
we continue to recognize the Supreme
Court rightfully returned the power of
protecting The Unborn to the people yet
we must never be complacent in our moral
duty to stand up for the sanctity of
Life today we'll take up two measures
supporting that very notion first of all
we'll consider HR 6914 the pregnant
students Rights Act the goal of any
knowledge is to educate support and
empower the students as they chart their
path forward each pupil has a distinct
journey and I think we can all agree
that resources and guidance offered on
campus should reflect that this bill
ensures that pregnant students are well
informed about their rights and the
support they can access when making
consequential choices about their future
those expecting should know all the
options and tools available to them
they should not be discriminated against
or marginalized to believe that they
don't have life affirming alternative HR
6914 requires colleges and universities
to guarantee pregnant women are
forthrightly aware of their rights uh
educational accommodations and
protections under the law so women can
balance college and pregnancy furthering
the goal of maternal assistance we'll
also discuss HR 6918 the supporting
pregnant and parenting women and
families act the Biden Administration
has proposed a new discriminatory
regulation impacting expecting mothers
uh in need and uh would specifically ban
pregnancy centers from receiving federal
dollars through the temporary assistance
for needy families or tanif U program
the White House is stripping resources
from facilities that provide women and
families with Medical Services emotional
support and supplies like diapers and
parental excuse me prenatal vitamins the
result is American women having
diminished options for care and fewer
alternatives to abortion HR 6918 will
prevent the defunding of these critical
Health Center it's a direct step in
safeguarding access to care and support
needed as parents ready to bring a new
child into the world finally I'll turn
to house resolution
957 our Southern border has plunged into
unprecedented chaos under President
Biden his administration has lost
operational control and Unleashed a
full-blown humanitarian and security
crisis uh the the these lack policies uh
have incentivized an historic number of
illegal Crossings and the ramifications
are much more than the sheer numbers or
an overwhelmed border patrol just last
week New York City Elementary students
lost access to their school facility to
have migrants this is the only the
latest example of many negative
consequences faced by communities Across
the Nation in fact the only people
helped by this situation are drug
smugglers human traffickers and
terrorists the failure of the Biden
Administration to address these serious
blunders is long overdue uh house
resolution 957 calls upon President
Biden and his administration to end
their disastrous open borders policy
that have turned every state into a
border state I'll now yield to our
ranking member my good friend Mr
McGovern for any remarks he wishes to
make well thank you Mr chairman and um
and unfortunately we're once again
wasting more time this week on Extreme
magga culture wars first we have two
bills that are part of Republicans
ongoing push to ban abortion Nationwide
it's absurd I mean every single week
we're here with bills to criminalize
abortion ban abortion punish people who
get an abortion and push these extreme
bills that take away women's freedoms HR
6914 makes it harder for students to
receive complete and accurate
information on their rights and options
regarding abortion it omits any
requirements for schools to distribute
medically accurate and comprehensive
information regarding pregnancy
including information on abortion
Services rather than providing support
to students like ensuring that they have
better familyfriendly campus housing uh
accessible and affordable child care
flexible attendance policies and
lactation accommodations HR 6914
accomplishes only one goal stigmatizing
students who seek abortion care we also
have HR 6918 the supporting pregnant and
parenting women and families act a
deeply misguided name for a bill that
does no such thing we hear from
Republicans about how pro-life they are
I mean give me a break these bills
aren't about life because if they were
Republicans would be advancing policies
that actually support life we could be
addressing The Growing Child Care crisis
expanding access to Paid Family and
Medical Leave or tackling childhood
poverty or trying to end Hunger that
exists in this country amongst millions
and millions of children U I think my my
our former colleague Barney Frank from
Massachusetts I think put it accurately
when he said that Republicans seem to
believe that life begins at conception
but ends at Birth um instead it seems a
republican the Republican position is
that you know you know as I said you
know he was absolutely right because HR
6918 continues to divert federal dollars
intended for poor families to dangerous
anti-abortion centers that put Women's
Health at risk to be clear these
anti-abortion centers deceive people
seeking access to abortion care they are
not regulated and are frequently
non-medical meaning they can severely
jeopardize the health of women who go to
them to them and again it's no secret
that the House Republicans are working
towards a National Abortion ban the nrcc
chair recently said it himself voters
believe the Republican position is quote
we'll throw you in jail if you get an
abortion end quote and let me tell you
the voters are right that's what
Republicans want to do don't take my
word it's already happening across the
country from Texas to Kentucky to South
Carolina Republicans are advancing
legislation that seeks to criminalize
abortion care
we're also here today to consider
another extreme magga messaging bill on
the border this is a do nothing press
release in the form of a non-binding
resolution it's all about turning the
House of Representatives into the arm
into an arm of the uh of the Trump
campaign that's it uh and no matter how
many times Maga Republicans Scream and
Shout uh the border is not open H
Democrats have been have been ready from
day one of this Congress to work across
the aisle and develop a thoughtful
bipartisan solution to fix issues at the
border but Republicans don't want that
they don't want to solve any of the
border security problems because if
something were to get done Republicans
would no longer be able to campaign on
it and in fact speaker Johnson literally
gave away the game over the weekend he
told Republicans he doesn't want an
immigration or border deal with
Democrats because then they all can't
demagogue the issue it's pathetic this
is all about creating a distraction from
Republican disarray each measure we are
considering today Wast time as we Barrel
toward a government shutdown and this
Republican majority is still in chaos
they had a fifth rule go down uh last
week because of the turmoil in their own
conference they continue to bring us to
the brink of a government shutdown
despite the fact they've had months and
months to work on Appropriations and
they have no vision or plan to fight for
the American people who expect a heck of
a lot more from us than the these awful
awful bills and with that Mr chairman I
yeld back without objection any prepared
statements that our Witnesses may have
will be included in the record I'd like
to welcome our first panel two of our
very good friends uh chairwoman Virginia
Fox and ranking member Bobby Scott from
the committee on education and Workforce
chairman Fox I welcome your
testimony thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank the members for being here and uh
I thank the ranking member for that
tribute to and uh for calling attention
to the impact that diabetes has in this
country uh thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for being here
HR 6914 the pregnant students Rights Act
offers a conduit through which pregnant
women who are students can receive both
guidance and assistance during a deeply
personal and sensitive time in their
lives this legislation would ensure that
universities offer the appropriate
breadth of resources and information so
Pregnant students can carry a baby to
term while continuing their education
this includes allowing female students
to change a class schedule to attend
doctor visits what's more this
legislation will properly inform
pregnant students of their recourse to
file a Title Nine complaint with the
Department of Education Mr chairman the
core of this legislation is about
ensuring unfettered and convenient
access to information HR 6914 requires
information to be mailed regularly to
students and appear in student handbooks
at each orientation at student health or
counseling centers and on the
institution's website caring for an
unborn child while pursuing rigorous
postsecondary coursework is certainly
not an easy LIF it's a reality that many
face without the tools that this
legislation would ensure I urge the
committee to support h charge 6914 and I
yield back ranking member Scott you're
now recognized for your opening
statement thank you chairman Cole
ranking member of mcgoverin and thank
you for um entering into the record uh
Dan turon's obituary at Out Lines a very
inspiring and remarkable life so thank
you very much members of the rules
committee this evening I'm speaking in
opposition to HR
6914 so-called pregnant students rights
act on its spaceil may appear to ensure
pregnant students are informed of
resources available to them and how they
can continue to access their education
while pregnant the impact regrettably is
much more Sinister it attempts to
dissuade students from considering their
full reproductive options and makes it
even more difficult for them to get full
and accurate information about their
rights including rights that are already
protected under the title n of the
education amendments under
1972 and let me repeat everything in the
bill is already protected under Title 9
as the bill provides information about
some of those rights under Title Nine
including how to including how to
complain how to file a complaint with
the Department of Education however the
information in the bill is only partial
in that it leaves many pregnant students
like those who are facing pregnancy loss
or those who are choosing to terminate
their pregnancy in the dark about their
rights under federal civil rights law so
it does not provide students with um a
description of all of their rights just
some of their rights selective rights
students already face numerous
challenges on campus including mental
health problems financial and Foods
insecurity academic uh difficulties name
a few regrettably this bill would make
life even more challenging for students
by omitting the comprehensive sexual and
reproductive health information they
actually need for
example the bill fails to require
schools to inform students about
contraception which would help students
avoid unplanned pregnancies their rights
and resources if they experience a
miscarriage and vital resources if they
need to terminate a pregnancy due to
health related
emergencies additionally if a student
decides to carry a child a term this
bill would not even provide any
additional funding such as child care
nutrition affordable housing options or
other CR critical support so the bill
provides partial information but no help
that's why dozens of health and
Reproductive Rights organizations such
as the National Women's Law Center the
National Partnership of women and
families and the American Civil Liberty
Union have stated that HR 6914 quote
fall Falls far short of the protections
that are actually necessary for pregnant
and parenting students in their in their
children in conclusion Mr chairman women
should be able to control their own
bodies and Futures but by keeping
students in the dark about their health
care choices resources and rights
available to them HR 6914 would deprive
pregnant students of their right to
decide what is best for them and their
families while offering no services in a
post Rogue World where women face State
sanction abortion bans and complicated
legal situations and challenges to
access health care we should be working
to inform women and children women and
students of all of their productive of
their reproductive rights and
protections this bill just does the
opposite so I oppose the legislation and
urge my colleagues to do the same look
forward to your questions and you'll
back I thank our Witnesses for their
testimony the chair will forego any uh
opening questions and now turn to the
distinguished Vice chairman of the
committee Dr Burgess for any questions
you might have for our panel thank you
Mr chairman just before I get to
questions I just have to say the problem
at the border is not an immigration
problem it is a security problem and
this country needs to wake up and
recognize that and deal with it as such
all of the happy talk about immigration
reform is not going to solve the problem
that exists today in Texas then by proxy
in other states around the country now
the bill in front of us today Dr Fox I
appreciate your eloquent summary you
describe it as a to it for guidance and
assistance and I I think that's exactly
right
um I'm
I'm at a loss to explain the statement
of administration policy that opposes
this I I can't see why they would be why
the president would be opposed to a
conduit for guidance and assistance
um it's U you know I'll I'll have to
leave it to them to explain why the uh
why the The veto threat exists but
I appreciate you all doing the work on
this I appreciate the the work that you
did in taking testimony and arriving at
the conclusion writing the legislation
and look forward to voting for it on the
floor thank you Mr chairman I'll yield
back thank you I now turn to my very
good friend the ranking member for any
questions he might have for that well I
I'll ask you animous consent to ensure
in the record the statement of
administration policy without objection
uh and I
mean there's nothing really to say here
I mean uh this is another in a series of
really bad bills that uh I think really
is offensive to women and um and so I
will I will I will speak about this on
the floor tomorrow you back thank you
very much and I'll go to my good friend
from M from Pennsylvania for any uh
questions he might have thank you Mr
chairman I appreciate it I just want to
thank both Witnesses for coming in and
providing testimony and with that I Y
back thank you very much and now go to
my other very good friend from
Pennsylvania gentle lady is recognized
for any question she may have for the
now thank you um I appreciate the um
list of um measures which would actually
help promote um the health and
well-being of student parents um which
the um ranking member Mr Scott listed I
would add to that you know information
if you have a child born with a
disability on what kinds of services and
supports might be necessary because that
obviously also comes into um play here
talking about um students having
children um but I I too am very
concerned by the fact that this uh is a
very clumsy attempt to put a fist on the
scale with respect to um promoting the
anti-abortion agenda and one only has to
look at the finding sections of this
bill which repeats a Litany of
anti-abortion uh allegations unsupported
by facts and so for that reason I will
be opposing this bill as well thank you
you back thank you very much now I
recognize very very good friend from
Minnesota for any questions she may have
for a p Mr chair you have a lot of good
friends so glad for you I try
to well first of all I just want to say
thank you uh chair chw Fox for bringing
this in front of us because I think that
it is important that we Empower women
with
information because if you have the more
information the more informed decision a
woman can make in whatever situation uh
they may be in and so I appreciate
having additional information for women
and I think I I wish that uh the other
side of the aisle would see that that it
is helpful to women for more information
and that's how they make an informed
choice but um and with that I thank you
for bringing it forward and I look
forward to voting for it on the floor
thank gentle lady and now recognize my
good friend from Colorado gentleman has
recognized for any questions he might
have for the panel I thank the chairman
uh and want to thank Madam chair uh and
a ranking member for their testimony
from being here uh today I want to
follow up on a point that my colleague
referenced about uh in particular HR
6914 uh the the pregnant students Rights
Act and this notion that that it's
designed to Simply provide more
information and so just to drill down a
bit on this Madame chair on page five of
the bill uh in section two it's titled
information content and I'll just read
this it's the information described in
this paragraph is the following sub
paragraph a a list of resources on
campus and in the community that exist
to help a pregnant student in carrying
the baby to term and caring for the baby
after birth do you see that language
there it's a sub paragraph a page five
sub paragraph
a sub paragraph a uhhuh it starts with a
list of resources okay so a list of
resources on campus and in the community
that exist to help a pregnant student in
carrying the baby to term and caring for
the baby after birth what are those
resources that this bill is
contemplating well it would depend on
the community it would it depend on what
the community has to offer uh for there
are no Universal resources irrespective
of what community you're in I mean I
take this language to be that the
federal you're acquiring these
institutions of higher education to
promulgate resources and you're saying
that every school's booklet is going to
be different
no we're saying that uh that what exists
we're not require them we're not
requiring them to create any additional
resources we're just asking them to to
provide a list of the resources on
campus and in the community there's no
requirement to create any resources so
what would those resources
be well um on there might might be on
trial campus uh facility um Child Care
Facilities there might be uh they'll be
probably uh in the community um Child
Care Facilities there might be um uh
information on um food pantries for
example if the if a student needed that
kind of help uh there might be
information on um pediatricians who are
in the area
let me follow on anybody can think if
you have a baby there what kind of
resources do you need sure well so with
respect to the food pantry it's a good
example I went online the American
Pregnancy Association has a list of
financial resources that are available
to pregnant mothers to to better inform
them about the resources that might be
available the first item on their list
is Wick women infants and children
supplemental fun program right are
you're familiar with Wick yes of course
right the special supplemental nutrition
program for women infants and children
it's the number one resource on this uh
website that I you know went on
and my understanding is that House
Republicans 190 of them in this Congress
voted to rescind $500 million in Wick
funding you recall that vote back in
September um not in particular the
numbers or anything about the vote well
I can represent to you that in September
of last year 190 House Republicans voted
to resend $500 million in Wick funding
um and that included you as well the
next item on the list here is pregnancy
Medicaid is listed as one of the
financial resources uh of course many
House Republicans most House Republicans
oppose the expansion of Medicaid and I
take it you do as
well is that a fair
assessment uh I that's a fair assessment
but I have no idea what that has to do
with this bill well this is a very
simple Bill to to help students it's a
very Pro student here's what I here's
what I'll suggest to you madam chair
this is why it matters the American
Pregnancy Association lists as Financial
Resources one of the those resources
available to pregnant women is pregnancy
Medicaid so that they can access health
care for them and for their child House
Republicans including yourself oppose
expanding Medicaid for pregnant mothers
and a variety of different states across
the country that's why it's relevant and
and as you can see where where I'm
struggling is understanding what
information you are compelling these
institutions of higher education to
actually provide to the extent that it's
any of these resources they're all
resources that House Republicans seem
intent on cutting and and those are just
a few I mean the next one on here is
temporary assistance for needy families
tanif again a program that House
Republicans have voted to decrease over
the course of this Congress so I guess
what I'm getting at and and maybe you
can help me understand this
is if the goal here is to Prov provide
as the bill says a list of resources to
assist pregnant
mothers and if we know those resources
pregnancy Medicaid tanif Wick a variety
of others are so critically important
why do House Republicans seem so intent
on cutting them all that that's really
my
question again um you're you're creating
a store of dog here this bill what was
that this bill is pro
student I surely members on both sides
of the aisle want to support women
becoming mothers and college graduates
there are resources now whether or not
we oppose some of those resources being
funded by taxpayers at the federal level
is irrelevant to this discussion they
exist since they exist So the plan then
the students should know about them and
take advantage of them as simple as that
you again you guys are throwing out
Straw Dogs constantly about this bill
Madam chair I would simply say it seems
to me the plan is to mandate the
provision of a list of resources of
programs that Republicans are trying to
dismantle in Washington I don't really
understand the utility in compelling the
production of a list that says hey
supplemental nutrition assistance
program resources are available to you
unless Republicans have a majority in
the Congress in which case it's not
worth much more than the piece of paper
that this bill apparently is compelling
the production of but again I'm not I I
guess what I would say Madam chair and
it's with all respect I would be far
more interested I think in debating and
moving forward a bill that funds these
resources that funds these critical
programs tan Wick snap panding Medicaid
uh to ensure that pregnant mothers have
those resources as opposed to passing a
bill that mandates the creation of a
list that list them out ranking member
Scott I know I want to give you an
opportunity I'd like to respond to that
we are the education committee we're
dealing with students we're not the
Appropriations Committee that's Mr Cole
and other folks uh so so perhaps um
since Mr Cole's here he can hear you say
what you want funded what should be
funded is not in our person you but
these things already exist and so we
just want to make sure that students are
aware of them and can we want the
students to be taken care of we want
their babies to be taken care of we want
them to complete their college education
and so whatever exists they should have
access to it and if they don't already
know about it we want the school to tell
them very simple Bill very Pro student
not anti anything we're not here to
speak against Wick or any of those
things that's a different subject thank
you I I hear you madam chair and I hope
the appropriators hear us as well I'm
not on the Appropriations Committee but
I the only caveat I suppose I would add
is that you keep on referencing these
programs existing they exist for now Al
Republicans have worked very hard to cut
them to the Bone over the last 14 months
so uh you know I the fact that you'd
like to provide a GU a list of resources
around Wick or snap or tanif to pregnant
mothers while the house Republican
majority seeks to defund all of these
programs just seems a bit um
disconnected in My View From the the
views and the values uh and the wishes
of the American people but rank member
Scott I want to give you an opportunity
to thank you and I think your comments
highlight a real shortcoming of the
legislation it gives partial information
to begin with doesn't give any
information on contraception
resources if you experien a miscarriage
if you're going to choose to terminate
the pregnancy for for any reason just
gives you partial information and then
in terms of resources doesn't give you
anything um so that's um if you are
trying to make an informed decision you
can't make an informed decision if
you're only hearing one
side I would also say to the gentle lady
from Pennsylvania when you talked about
the allegations we did did ask for a
documentation for the um uh findings and
the sponsor of many of the one of the
major parts of that finding was unable
to provide
documentation I than the Riki member I
thank the chair uh and uh I yield
announcement thank you Gentle lady from
New Mexico recognized for any questions
she might have for the panel thank you
Mr chair
um madam chairwoman uh both today and at
the hearing there is a statement that
this is about providing information uh
to pregnant women uh to make sure that
they can make informed decisions as my
colleague from Pennsylvania puted out
the findings of this bill tell you what
is about this is a bill to attack the
ability of college women to make
informed decisions and to make decisions
about whether or not they want to have
an abortion and whether or not uh if
they choose to carry the pregnancies how
to do it uh and how to do it in a way
that makes it healthy for themselves and
for their children especially because we
know that uh College mothers have a hard
time that they uh go hungry more often
than uh their counterparts who aren't um
mothers who don't carry children car
carry children determined so we need to
give them the kind of resources that
they deserve uh but it's really once
again you know extreme Republicans just
want to keep ring in the dark that's
what this bill tells me because they
don't really want to know what's
available to them in committee markup
representative gy Paul submitted an
amendment to provide pregnant students
with information about the kinds of
essential programs we're talking about
so that their babies can stay healthy
like Medicaid like Snap like women
infant and children uh so this would
have been an amendment which if we care
about providing women with information
uh would have been I would have thought
supported by Republicans chairwoman Fox
tell me how many Republicans voted for
representative gy Paul's
Amendment oh I don't believe any did so
there was Zero Republicans who cared
about providing pregnant college women
with information they need to keep their
uh babies healthy to keep themselves
healthy while they're pregnant I'm sorry
uh voted against that every single one
voted against that Amendment there was
another amendment representative Stevens
submitted an amendment to make sure that
pregnant students would have information
about
miscarriages because we know that 10 to
20% of pregnancies result in
miscarriages she had an impassioned
speech about the importance of making
sure that pregnant college women knew
about this so that they could say save
their own lives if necessary because we
keep reading about the stories of women
who are pregnant in States like Texas
and across this country who cannot get
the care they need because of the
Draconian laws and so miscarriages are
becoming a source of potential death for
women so how many Republicans voted for
representative uh Stevens Amendment uh
chairwoman uh my memory is none not a
single one so this isn't about making
sure that women have information because
if it were to have full information
they'd have full information and
Republicans have said no and these
Provisions aren't just smart they're
good Public Health policy decisions we
should be about in Congress saying what
is good for public health how do we do
that how do we make sure that women have
full access to information uh and you
know I want to keep Congress I want to
keep Congress out of the doctor's office
when women are making decisions I want
to keep Congress out of the doctor's
office whether you're a woman in Rural
America in urban America Suburban
America or on a college campus because
women deserve to be making these
decisions with full information with
conversations with their own faith their
own Doctrine their own loved ones and we
should not be dictating that they follow
what's in this bill uh and for that you
know I would urge my colleagues to vote
against this I don't know if you want to
add anything ranking member I think
you've said it very well okay thank you
with that are you back may I may I speak
on that m l recognized this
bill contrary to my colleague saying
keeps women in the dark does everything
we can to help students with female
students who find themselves pregnant
and who want to carry their baby to term
this is not at all about any of the
issues that our colleagues were talking
about what we assume is all of the
things that are going all the resources
will be listed we did not see a need to
try to list certain resources that are
available we want the schools to assume
what to list this is a very pro- student
bill it says absolutely nothing about
abortion uh it's totally
mischaracterized by our colleagues on
the other side of the aisle we assume
again that everybody wants pregnant
women to pregnant students to have the
best information that they can to be
successful and to carry their babies
successfully it's impossible to
understand the characterization of this
piece of legislation I yield back thank
you very very much the gentleman from
Texas has asked recognition for make a
comment just Mr chairman if I could for
a point of clarification Medicaid
created in
1965 a shared federal state
program had within it several
populations that were going to be
covered blind aged disabled feeble
elderly pregnant women and children
under a certain income level that was
the original I refer to it often times
as the Legacy population in Medicaid
when the Affordable Care Act passed
Medicaid was vastly expanded to include
childless non-working adults Supreme
Court said States can't be coerced into
expanding Medicaid so some states did
some states did not but in states that
did not you still have coverage as a
pregnant individual a pregnant woman
because that was the original compact in
the state of Texas its 57% Federal share
uh
43% State share that is the law that
existed prior to the Affordable Care Act
and whether or not irrespective of
Medicaid expansion that coverage is
available to pregnant women what I do
need to add is in the past couple of
years the committee on Energy and
Commerce has done a lot of work on this
in an effort to deal with problems that
occur after childb birth it was decided
that a longer period of coverage after
delivery should
be available to States and so a state
plan option was made available and
passed into law that states can extend
coverage to a full year after delivery
which I think is a good idea but it was
not an expansion of Medicaid it was
taken care of of the original population
in the way it was supposed to be taken
care of and I just wanted to make that
clarification Mr chairman because
sometimes these things get conflated and
I'll yield back thank you very much
there any additional questions or
comments oh Mr chairman gentle ladies
recognize thank you and uh the uh
chairwoman um noted that this bill has
said nothing about abortion I would just
point out for the record that uh on uh
uh page three line 11 there is a
reference to abortion on line 12 there
is a reference to abortion on line 20
there is a reference to abortion on line
four on page four line one there's a
reference to abortion on line uh page
four line line four there's a reference
reference to abortion on L page four
line 10 there is a reference to abortion
this bill is very much about abortion
and with that you'll back thank you Mr
chair thank you very much I want to
thank both of our Witnesses for their
testimony today and uh General lady and
gentleman are excused you thank
you
I'd like to welcome our second panel uh
representative fishbach you can deliver
either from your chair or that would be
fine from the committee on Ways and
Means and uh representive fishbach I
welcome your
testimony
this is my first time before the rules
committee so be
kind gent ladies recognized for
Testimony thank you Mr chair um today
we're considering the supporting
pregnant and parenting women fam and
families act which would block the Bing
Administration rule that attempts to
divert resources away from Pregnancy
Resource Centers that provide
life-saving and life affirming services
and resources to pregnant women and
their families I am proud to have
introduced this legislation along with
my ways and means colleague
representative Claudia chenny from New
York who couldn't be here because she is
uh her flight is delayed and
representative Chris Smith from New
Jersey in October of last year the
Department of Health and Human Services
published a proposed rule that would
that could prohibit States from funding
Pregnancy Resource Centers through the
temporary assistance for needy families
or tanif the block program block grant
program excuse me if this rule takes
effect women in America will have fewer
alternatives to abortion and less access
to maternal care the supporting pregnant
and parenting women and families act
protects pregnant women from women's
access to maternal Care by prohibiting
HHS from finalizing implementing or
enforcing the proposed rule as it
relates to placing restrictions on the
state use of Tanis tanif dollars for
Pregnancy Resource Centers Pregnancy
Resource Centers provide vital resources
used by pregnant and parenting women
every day to support the health and
pregnancy of their
child nothing in by nothing in the
bipartisan law that created tanif
provides the Biden Administration the
authority to regulate TANF in this
manner and unfairly single out and
Target these centers Pregnancy Resource
Centers provide everything from diapers
food food baby clothes Transportation
parenting classes relationship education
and prenal vitamins they provide both
emotional support and tangible benefits
and materials to women with unplanned
pregnancies that clearly meet the
purposes of tanif to provide assistance
to needy families and reduce dependence
on government assistance flexibility for
states to use tanif dollars is at the
heart of the bipartisan law that created
the the block grant in
1996 in fact the primary goal of the
legislation was to increase the
flexibility of states which is exactly
why Congress explicitly prohibited
Federal bureaucrats from telling States
how and where to spend these funds the
Biden Administration is attempting to
sidestep congress with the proposed rule
which is a clear violation of the law
while furthering their agenda to
mischaracterize and spread false
information of the goals and purpose of
Pregnancy Resource Centers no one says
Tanis tanif is perfect but the role of
improving the program lies with congress
not only as the Biden Administration
ignoring the law but in the process they
are also penalizing vulnerable women
trying to protect their own health and
the health of their
children Democrats claim to support a
woman's right to choose their own health
care but at this moment the Biden
Administration is preparing to make it
harder for moms to choose life for their
unborn child as well as how they will
take care of themselves mes and their
babies if this rule takes effect
pregnant women in America will have few
fewer alternatives to abortion and less
access to vital services and support
Congress must send a clear message that
we will not tolerate Federal bureaucrats
ignoring the letter of the law and we
will stand up and support women women
should not be denied access to these
critical centers for the sake of a
political agenda I hope that each one of
my colleagues will support this
legislation to stop the Biden admin
administration's attack on pregnant and
parenting mothers and their families and
thank you Mr chairman and members thank
you very much uh obviously the weather's
made travel difficult I'm recognizing my
uh friend from Pennsylvania Miss
scanland for any I think to read into
the record a statement by representative
Pew who obviously had travel
difficulties in getting here today as
well yes not everyone's as hearty as the
members of the rules committee but uh
travel has certainly been difficult for
people um my colleague representative
Chu couldn't be here so I she has asked
me to present her remarks on
6918 Mr chairman and ranking member
McGovern I'm dismayed that today the
rules committee meets not to consider
serious legislation that will improve
the lives of Americans but to consider a
bill merely intended to score political
points with attendees at this week's
anti-abortion rally here in Washington
this partisan Republican bill HR
6918 would divert funds from needy
children and families to anti-abortion
centers these so-called crisis pregnancy
centers masquerade as healthc care
facilities usually providing misleading
or inaccurate medical information in
order to prevent women from seeking
abortions specifically the bill would
block the Biden Administration from
monitoring State spending of temporary
assistance for needy families or tanif
dollars for so-called crisis pregnancy
centers in effect it would permanently
exempt from regulation and oversight
State expenditure of federal tan of
dollars on these centers everyone
deserves access to accurate information
when making Health Care decisions
anti-abortion centers are not legitimate
Health Care Providers rather they are
organizations attempting to coer
pregnant people seeking abortions into
carrying pregnancies to term using
manipulation and misinformation they
often disguise themselves as Genuine
Health Centers even going so far as to
dress their staff in scrubs or white
coats to mimic medical professionals
because these anti-abortion centers are
not actual medical facilities they're
not covered by the privacy and security
rules of HIPPA and therefore their staff
can say whatever they want without
consequence so these centers POS as
medical facilities spread misinformation
about abortion and then face little if
any consequences for doing so this has
profound impact for the patients that
find their way to these centers
believing falsely that their staff are
real medical professionals in Iowa and
OBGYN has seen patients who visited
these centers and we're told that using
contraceptives was the same as having an
abortion that using birth control could
give them cancer and would damage their
overall health in Massachusetts one of
these centers failed to correctly
diagnose an ectopic pregnancy because
the staff member conducting her
ultrasound wasn't qualified to be
conducting that test the woman later
required emergency surgery and in my
home state this is from uh rep of
Califor California our attorney general
has sued one operator of these centers
for their false claims of offering
so-called abortion reversal which is a
procedure that not only does not exist
but attempts to implement it can cause
life-threatening hemorrhaging in women a
recent study of 607 anti-abortion
centers across nine states covering
almost 2third of these anti-abortion
centers found that they quote promoted
patently false Andor biased medical
claims about pregnant pregnancy abortion
contraceptive and reproductive healthare
providers unquote fewer than half
reported having a licensed Medical
Professional on staff during our markup
last week Democrats offered a series of
amendments to allow funding to these
centers if they could be demonstrated to
provide medically accurate information
not harm women's health or economic
Futures and did not mislead women as to
their purpose or use coercion to get
them to visit them committee Republicans
rejected all of those amendments making
clear that their purpose is coercive
propaganda not support for pregnant
women if you want to support parents
Democrats on the Ways and Means
Committee would welcome the support for
things like the enhanced and increased
child tax credit Paid Family and Medical
Leave and making Child Care affordable
for Working Families instead we are
debating a bill that has no hope of
becoming law that is not a serious
attempt to help families and that is
merely an attempt to appease is a farri
fringe group in town for its annual
conference in fact this bill is to
serious pro- family legislation what
so-called crisis pregnancy centers are
to actual responsible Medical Care a
sham masquerading is something helpful
the best we can do to support pregnant
women and families today is to reject
this legislation with that I yield the
balance of this choose time I thank
gentle lady for reading our colleague
statement into the record I have no
question for our Witnesses I'll go next
to my friend Dr Burgess no questions
chairman I want to thank our both our
Witnesses both in obena in front of us I
have had the opportunity to visit
pregnancy centers in my district I found
to be staffed by very compassionate
people they provide access to
information about things like formula
diapers and what other resources are
available in the community so I think
they are important and uh a little bit
mystified as to to why the
Administration has singled them out for
for criticism but thank you um to our
colleague Miss fishbach for for bringing
this and uh look forward to voting for
it on the floor tomorrow thank you
gentlemen from Massachusetts recognize
for any questions he may have yeah and
um Let me let me the Miss Chu referenced
in her um in her testimony a
Massachusetts um uh Pregnancy Center
that happens to be in my district U not
too far from my district office and in
Worcester and um it is uh and the reason
why there's concern is because um
Somebody almost died uh because the
people they were not medically qualified
to understand um all that their need all
that you need to understand for a woman
to be able to have a aafe pregnancy and
a complaint was filed against that um uh
Center
um Bas basically saying they engage in
deceptive advertis in aim to aiming to
persuade women to forgo abortions rather
than providing them with the range of
medically appropriate options and the
plaintive who's a Worcester resident one
of my
constituents um alleges that the
so-called nurse who performed the
ultrasound scan at the center did not
understand sufficient medical measures
to ensure the pregnancy was VI viable an
ectopic pregnancy uh was what she was
dealing with occurs when a fertilized
egg implants in grows outside of the
uterus most often in the fallopian tube
such pregnancies are usually nonviable
and they can be
life-threatening and um the suit alleges
that the women's fallopian tube ruptured
about a month after the ultrasound scan
causing massive internal bleeding and
necessitating emergency
surgery um and the my constituent's not
saying that the that the uh nurse or
whoever it was intentionally misled her
instead they're saying that that the
staffer missed the ectopic pregnancy
because she wasn't qualified to do this
so if we're talking about protecting
viable pregnancies and we're talking
about protecting The Mother We need to
make sure that they're going to places
that are properly equipped and staffed
uh to do what is best for the mother in
this case that did not happen that did
not happen uh and the idea that you're
diverting tan Monies to help at risk
families and children to support a
political agenda that quite frankly is
terribly unpopular in this country it's
one of the reasons why you're all losing
elections um I find to be really
disturbing so I uh I I will oppose this
bill uh but um I mean I you
know this
Obsession uh with
um with trying to roll back women's
rights when it comes to access to
abortion or
proper Health Care guidance um is
something I just don't quite understand
but in any event uh I think the only
thing is that this will go nowhere even
if it passes the house but that case
that Mr you referred to happened to be
in my district uh you back thank you g
lady from Pennsylvania is recognize for
any questions you may have um I I don't
really have any questions I think we
should all be able to agree on the
importance of supporting maternal and
infant care particularly given the
shocking rate of maternal mortality in
this country um and particularly for
women of color but that's not what this
bill does this bill tries to block a
Federal Regulation of these pregnancy
centers despite the growing body of
evidence that many of these centers are
deceiving people about whether or not
they're actually providing Health Care
and they're misusing diverting and um
actually defrauding um Federal taxpayers
of dollars that are sent to these places
in multiple States including
Pennsylvania and
Minnesota um that are not supporting the
goals of tanif so this is almost an
oversight function that the federal
government has been responding to these
reports um which are growing in number
about the misuse of federal dollars in
these Pregnancy Crisis centers and
trying to make sure that those dollars
are only spent for the purposes if we
were just talking about diapers and
formula we wouldn't the the um
Department of Human Services would not
have issued this regulation what we're
talking about is misuse of federal
dollars um with deceptive um quote
medical unquote practices and um
actually diversion of dollars in
Pennsylvania there's been a major
contract that's been terminated because
it turned out that they were taking
dollars
uh that had flowed from the federal
government through Pennsylvania um and
diverting them to other places and not
actually using them to provide services
to um mothers and children but for
overhead in other states so I think it's
an appropriate function for the federal
government I think it's a mistake to try
to block um the the administration from
trying to make sure that these dollars
are spent in the way that Congress
intended and I yield back gentleman from
Colorado recognized for any question
questions he may
have and gentle lady from New Mexico is
recognized for any questions she may
have thank you uh and thank you uh
representative uh scandin for reading
the statement uh and especially pointing
out that the reason we're having these
bills when we should be working on
funding our government is because
there's a rally going up so this is such
a political stunt and you know more
political theater attacking abortion
uh and and to the state to the statement
that these uh crisis pregnancy centers
are just providing information um Mr
chairman uh I would ask unanimous
consent to enter into the record an
issue brief about crisis pregnancy
centers from the American College of
Obstetricians and
gynecologists objection so this issue's
brief actually describes how these
centers are are famous and actually use
uh inaccurate information and end up
doing things like what we heard about uh
that puts women's lives at risk one of
the misleading practices that these
Centers do is they assert false risks of
abortion they say there are links
between abortion and breast cancer
infertility mental illness and pre-term
birth uh they uh have a long list of uh
the misinformation that they provide
including saying there are legal limits
to abortion when they are not uh they
cause delays in legitimate Health Care
by delaying when women can actually get
access to True Health Care the doctors
that I talked about earlier that women
should be able to consult without
interference by politicians um that when
you delay that you can delay uh
assessing difficulties of pregnancy
whether you choose to keep it pregnancy
such as if you're diabetic or other
things or choosing to terminate the
pregnancy so that you don't go beyond
limits as states are now imposing six
week limits four- week limits 8we limits
whatever limits they're doing and by
delaying that you are actually delaying
a woman's choice and so I think that you
know it is wise for us to listen to the
American College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists they are the experts in
this realm and so uh I you know would
enter that into the record I also am
very curious as I read through the
record of how this moved through uh
committee that we actually had
representative Del Benny submitting uh
an amendment that said pregnancy centers
cannot provide medically inaccurate
information just holding them to that
standard that's not such a high stand
are like be accurate and Republicans
voted that Amendment down so once again
we keep seeing Republicans voting down
amendments to try to make these bills
actually scientific based and
Republicans keep saying no and I think
this should tell the American public
Republicans do not want our women to
have accurate medical information about
their health care choices period we need
to hold them accountable able and we say
that's not acceptable we will make our
decisions and we will make those
decisions and we'll make sure they are
heard at the ballot boxes which is what
we have seen over and over again every
time this issue of reproductive freedom
of healthare and women being able to
have the freedom to make their own
health care decisions in conversation
with their own faith whatever that Faith
may be that that women are speaking
loudly and I hope they keep speaking
loudly so that politicians like those
who have brought this bill will stay out
of their doctor's office and with that I
yield back thank you Mr chairman Jal 's
recognized response Mr chair thank you
um it comes from the fact that the Biden
Administration chose to Target these
life affirming centers they the the the
Pregnancy Care Centers were receiving
tanet fund so it's not diverting it's
not um adding them this is already this
is already this t of dollars going to
those Pregnancy Care Centers is is is
existing and the Biden Administration
chose to go after
them what they are doing is limiting
State flexibility because the states
have the flexibility right now to choose
or to not to send it where they want
that is the purpose of the tanif the way
that the tanif uh bill was written the
program was put
together many of the crisis pregnancy
centers adhere to National standards
they are part of an national network
they adhere to standards and ethics um
and I I have been to a Pregnancy Care
Center just like uh Dr Burgess has been
and what you see is you see caring
compassionate people who are there to
care for the mother and the child during
pregnancy and after pregnancy and many
many many we heard we had stories in um
during the ways and means uh markup on
this bill that talked about uh you know
many years of being supported by these
Pregnancy Care Centers and children that
grew up and I do believe it was Dr wests
Who is uh who has wife uh worked at a
Crisis Pregnancy Center or volunteered
at a Crisis Pregnancy Center this is not
um what the other side wants to make it
out to be these are good places helpful
places they care for the mother and the
child and that's why you you hear about
you know you hear about the the
fundraising that they do to add to the
TANF dollars so this is this is actually
a value for us because they do a lot of
private fundraising they do a lot of
fundraising for baby items so that uh so
that they can send uh send home with the
mother and the baby cribs diapers
whatever it may be and and so it it's
not just it's not these Pregnancy Care
Centers are not what the other side is
trying to make them out to be thank you
Mr chair thank you very much uh thank
you for appearing before us today gentle
ladies is excused and we hope she
returns to the
Das I'd like to welcome our third panel
uh representative Nathaniel Moren and
ranking member Gerald Nadler from the
committee on the
Judiciary
thank you very much represenative Mor
you're recognized for your opening
statement thank you Mr chairman um Mr
chairman I'm here I'm on uh hres 957
denouncing the Biden administration's
open border policies I want to thank you
for allowing me the opportunity to be in
front of the committee President Biden's
own actions tell us that he has never
been a fan of a secure US border during
the 2020 election then candidate Biden's
campaign promises included rolling back
president Trump's successful Board of
security policies restarting Catch and
Release and offering amnesty to illegal
aliens in the United States
unfortunately he has made good on these
promises within a few days of taking
office President Biden halted border
Wall's construction terminated the
remaining Mexico program and reversed
policies that successfully cut down on
frivolous Asylum claims and
systematically dismantled IMR ation
enforcement right away House Republicans
started sounding the alarm that
reversing the Trump Administration
policies would lead to a flood of
illegal aliens on the Southwest border
and we weren't the only ones sounding
the alarm in fact the US border patrol
had warned the Biden transition team
that reversing these policies would be
seen as a sign that our border was open
the Biden Administration did it anyway
and today we know House Republicans and
the border patrol were right the text of
my proposed house resolution is simple
and straightforward it denounces the
Biden administration's open border
policies it condemns the National
Security and public crisis that the
president has caused and it urges
President Biden to end these open border
policies if you're wondering why we need
that to pass this resolution it's simple
because some still denies that a crisis
is occurring and some deny that the
president and his administration bear
any responsibility for it but the Border
numbers do not lie in fact they tell us
a clear story about the depth of this
crisis and a approximate cause rooted in
Biden's Administration policies consider
that the total number of illegal aliens
encountered along the southern border
under President Biden exceeds 7 million
at the same time the Biden
Administration has released at least 3.3
million of those illegal aliens into the
interior of the United States this
number is larger than the entire
population of States like Nevada
Arkansas and Kansas additionally more
than 1.7 million getaways and an Untold
number of unknown illegal Al alien Goda
aways have successfully evaded capture
by US border patrol along the Southwest
border 312 illegal aliens on the
terrorist screening data set were
encountered along the Southwest border
since Biden took office by contrast
consider that in four years under the
Trump Administration a total of only 11
illegal aliens on the tsds were
encountered by border patrol more than
785,000 migrant encounters have been
reported just since the beginning of
this fiscal year October 1 that's the
highest first quarter total ever
recorded in fiscal year 23 27,000 pounds
of fentanyl were seized at the southern
border this is almost double fiscal year
22 and it's six times larger than fiscal
year 20 March 2023 report by the Council
on Foreign Relations found that
152,000 unaccompanied miners were found
at the US Mexico border in fiscal year
2022 presently the Biden Administration
has lost contact with this as many as
85,000 of these
uac's until 2012 most of those
encountered by the border of Patrol in
fact about 85% were citizens of Mexico
but the landscape has changed in fiscal
year 22 migrants from Mexico crossing
illegally made up just
33% now individuals are coming from more
than 150 different countries and many of
these countries have direct ties to
terrorism the crisis is real and it's
getting worse because the world knows
President Biden will do nothing to
defend the physical borders of our
nation so what's the result President
Biden's open border policies have
resulted in a significant threat to our
national security and have caused a
public safety crisis in the interior of
the United States overcrowded classrooms
childhood children traffic to work in
Industries unsuited for children
millions in unpaid medical bills and
hospitals across the US overwhelmed
First Responders in Border communities
border patrol agents who feel like
travel agents homeless veterans who get
kicked out of shelter sh in favor of
illegal aliens and even the deaths of
innocent vict uh Americans and these
effects are being felt in Rural and
Metropolitan communities in both red and
blue States as of the beginning of
December the city of Denver had spent
over 33 million to house feed and
educate around 30,000 illegal aliens
Chicago residents are up in arms about
the money spent on illegal alien
shelters in their communities when the
taxpaying residents themselves have been
asking for and denied additional
services for years the new New York city
mayor continues to lament the illegal
aliens being busted into that City uh
will destroy quote destroy the
city in 2022 73,000 people died of
fentanyl overdose in the US this is more
than double the deaths in
2019 and the highest in American history
assaults on Border Patrol agents have
doubled in the last year nevertheless
the B Administration is doubling down on
its open border policies what will it
take for this Administration to wake up
and take action house resolution 957
denounces Biden administration's open
border policies condemns the National
Security and Public Safety crisis that
the Administration has caused and urges
the president to end his open borders
agenda it's simple and to the point and
the American people deserve its passage
I yield back thank you very much uh
ranking member natal you're recognized
for your opening statement chairman Cole
ranking member McGovern thank you for
the opportunity to test IFI today in
this resolution this country is facing
real problems there is an erosion of
trust in our government and institutions
the right to bodily autonomy is under
attack Across the Nation there was a
school shooting just four days into the
new year leading to the tragic death of
an 11year old and the injury of seven
others our immigration system cannot
function because Congress has failed to
reform it for over 30 years and we are
just days away from large parts of our
government shutting down but instead of
working to respond to to these problems
House Republicans are fighting among
themselves their inability to govern led
to another failed rule vote last week
and has brought us to the brink of a
government shutdown the historic
dysfunction has prompted multiple
members of their conference to complain
that they have nothing to campaign on
but instead of laying out a legislative
agenda to address the needs of the
American people we are here in the rules
committee to discuss a pointless border
resolution this resolution will do
nothing to solve the situation at the
border
it proposes no Solutions of any kind in
fact this resolution is nothing more
than a highlight re of the Republican
talking points in Immigration that we
have heard over and over from
Republicans since President Biden was
sworn into office so let me say once
again the border is not open the Biden
Administration is removing people at a
very significant Pace in ways that I
have concerns about with respect to Due
Process since the end of title 42 last
May the Biden Administration has removed
or returned over 470,000 individuals and
members of family units this total is
nearly equivalent to the number of
people removed in all of fiscal year
2019 under the Trump
Administration but because President
Biden isn't saying that he wants to
shoot migrants trying to cross the
border like Governor Abbott and and Des
sanus have Republicans don't think he's
doing enough today there are
approximately 38,000 people in
immigration detention which is 4,000
more than what the Department of
Homeland Security is even funded for L
levels of detention similar to those
during fiscal year 2018 during the Trump
Administration and despite my colleagues
claims fenel is largely not coming into
this country between ports of Entry more
than 90% of fenel interdicted is stopped
at ports of Entry where cartels
attempted to smuggle through Prim arily
in vehicles driven by American city
citizens at ports of Entry that is why
DHS was able to stop over 43,000 pounds
of fenel from hitting our streets and
seized more than 3600 pill presses so
I'm not sure how anyone can say the bord
is open or that this Administration is
not enforcing our laws on top of this at
every turn Republicans have voted
against giving DHS the resources it
needs to do its job
in
2021 all but six current House
Republicans voted against the bipartisan
infrastructure deal which provided
additional funding to modernize ports of
entry and allow for non-intrusive
inspections to combat the smuggling of
people and
drugs likewise all but two current House
Republicans voted against providing
robust funding for Customs and Border
Protection and border security
operations in fiscal year 2023
appropriate ation Omnibus
legislation that bill provided more than
$17 billion of CBP including 60 million
to hire an additional 125 CBP officers
and $70 million for non-intrusive
inspection technology to detect
narcotics and Firearms at ports of
Entry when it comes to the president's
supplemental request which would provide
144 billion for border security we have
not had a single hearing let alone of
vote on the
request the president has requested
vital funds for 375 immigration judges
and, 1600 Asylum officers to speed up
processing of Asylum claims as well as
funds for additional Personnel reports
of entry and Technology to stop drugs
from coming into the country if we had
adequate numbers of Asylum officers and
immigration
judges We could decide these cases in
weeks not years you wouldn't have the
problem of of Catch and Release that the
Republicans are so fond of talking about
but the Republicans refuse to vote the
funds to solve that problem instead
Republicans in House Republicans insist
they will only consider hr2 their
Draconian enforcement only Bill that
would destroy the Asylum system gut
protections for unaccompanied kids and
end all parole programs policies that
stand no chance of passage in the Senate
which shows that they're not interested
in real solutions real solutions require
compromise and magga Republicans aren't
interested in compromise we need to work
together to address our broken
immigration system enforcement alone
cannot fix it we know this because that
approach has largely failed for three
decades we need to update our
immigration system so that it meets the
needs of our country we need a balanced
bipartisan approach that expands lawful
Pathways this will help relieve pressure
on the border and allow people to come
to this country country in an orderly
and efficient way this resolution
however is nothing but empty rhetoric
designed to score cheap political points
that brings us no closer to meaningful
reform I urge my colleagues to reject
this resolution and I'd be happy to
answer your questions I you back thank
both our Witnesses I'd asked you both uh
and uh I'll start with you represent D
are there more people or fewer people
coming into the country illegally in the
last three years than the three years
before well as I said there are probably
more people now no no there are
certainly more people not probably more
people it's certainly true that we're
seeing unprecedented migration at the
border that's due to a record number of
displaced people around the world World
Travel being shut down because of the
pandemic and the Trump administration's
gutting of legal immigration including
the Refuge program and we should work
together in bipartisan Solutions instead
of passing meaningless resolutions I ask
you the same question Mr morand are
there more people or fewer people coming
across our border illegally chairman
Cole there's significantly more people
coming across our border illegally in
the last three years than there were
under the prior Administration by
significant multiples okay if we uh and
again I'll ask you both if we U the
number of people claiming Asylum how
many actually when they cases are
adjudicated what's the percentage
roughly of people that we find
legitimately have
a Asylum
claim I don't know well I can tell you
it's uh roughly almost 90% of those
claims are not legitimate Asylum claims
that once are adjudicated Mr chairman
that makes my point that we should have
enough funding for enough Asylum judges
and Asylum officers so we can make those
determinations in weeks not in years
well if the the and that's what the bid
Administration the the president's
executive orders that he issued the very
first day he was elected or sworn in as
president uh you know made our borders
more secure or less
secure I think the fact of the matter is
that since the end of title 42 the bid
administrations approved or returned to
Mexico over 470,000 people including
over 78,000 individual members of family
units including children this total is
equivalent or almost equivalent to the
number of people removed in all the
fiscal year 2019 under the Trump
Administration if more people are coming
and you're only removing about the same
number aren't more people here
illegally yes more people are here
illegally but again then wouldn't it
been a good idea to keep the remain in
Mexico policy to continue to thew why no
because the good idea is to have enough
funding to be be able to adjudicate
these cases in weeks and remove the
people who don't deserve Asylum and and
have the people who do deserve Asylum be
able to be peacefully in this country
and get work permits that's what would
solve the problem and the Administration
has has uh has asked for that funding
and the Republicans have refused to vote
that funding that's what would solve the
problem chairman you control the
Congress until about a year
ago were there no increases in funding
when you had the house the Senate and
the presidency a lot of the numbers
you're talking about have gotten worse
when you were in complete control of
both the legislative and the executive
branch have you ever heard of the
filibuster or the filibuster I certainly
have okay that answers the question
didn't you control the United States
Senate didn't you control the house
votes by 60 votes
no I'm sorry the problem's gotten worse
on your watch not better go to Mr moram
with the same questions CH uh chairman
Cole I want to just address the fact
that funding is not the issue here
because funding is at some of the
highest levels in decades it's a matter
of Will and policy by the executive uh
by the executive branch in this in this
country and as it relates to needing
more judges to adjudicate matters
chairman you pointed out the correct
issue and that is we're seeing high
levels of Asylum claims that are granted
and lots of folks that even before their
Cas is adjudicated released some of whom
most of whom don't come back for their
adjudication they just stay within the
United States but what we saw when there
was the rain and Mexico policy was those
uh those incorrect claims of Asylum went
away because many people just didn't
want to get in the United States and be
released freely they knew they were
going to have to stay in Mexico or some
other country while their claim was
adjudicated they weren't willing to do
that because frankly they knew their
case was not worth being adjudicated so
by expanding that asylum definition and
by letting people go Within in the
interior of the United States we have
seen this rise in cases uh that is uh
overwhelming our uh immigration uh
system at this point when you go back
though to these numbers where ranking
member nler mentioned about the number
of folks that have been sent out of the
country now as opposed to earlier
chairman you hit the the nail on the
head I had a I had a flood in my house
of a water flood in my house during my
primary a couple years ago and the first
thing I did was go to the water man turn
it off because if I tried to clean up
the mess in my house while that water
was continuing to flood my house there's
going to be no way for me to catch up
and so the first thing to do is correct
the problem fix the issue and then clean
up what needs to be cleaned up on the
interior we're failing to do that by
failing to shut off the Border
itself I thank both gentlemen for their
answers now turn to my good friend the
ranking member for any questions you may
have well thank you um thank you both
for being here um let me just trying to
say say this um in the bill we're
talking about right now there's there's
not a not any additional funding for
border security or for um additional um
staff to adjudicate assignment claims
not an nle um and um if I that this
basically is simply a a bill to just
condemn the B Administration I mean
there's no there's no no there there
other than this is like a a statement of
condemnation is that it that's correct
is that what they spell is that ranking
remember what this bill does and the
reason why I I answered this question in
my comments opening statement was why do
we need this we need this for two
reasons one because uh folks on on the
Democratic side of the aisle refuse to
acknowledge that there's a crisis at the
border number one and number two they
refuse to acknowledge that it's a
largely largely a result of Biden's
policies and if that acknowledgement
were to happen this resolution likely
would not be needed I I think what
people are are looking for and I think
what many of many of our constituents
looking for are solutions right how do
we deal with this there's a lot of
reasons why people are coming to the
Border uh right now um you know the the
world is an unprecedented turmoil people
are coming from all over the world um
for a variety of reasons um and you know
that's one subject that maybe that we we
need
to to improve some of our foreign policy
initiatives but but it but you know but
it seems to me that
there is great consensus that you know
we need to beef beef up our border
security that's that doesn't solve
everything but that's one thing we can
do um it seems to me that Mr n is
suggesting about additional funds for
you know to help uh process Asylum
claims seems like a reasonable thing to
do and I think that Democrats and
Republicans could agree on that I mean
there's an old saying that you don't
have to agree on everything to agree on
something so there's something we agree
on we got to get done and we ought to
move forward um but here's what I worry
about Mr Moran I I worry about and I and
I say this um not with any disrespect
but I really think that some of my
Republican friends are not interested in
solving the problem they're interested
in a political issue and I say that and
maybe you were on this call uh where
reports about house Speaker Mike Johnson
privately told House Republicans that he
will not accept whatever border security
deal comes out of the current talks
between the Senate and the White House
um a GOP lawmaker familiar with the call
said we don't even know what that deal
is um and were you on that call with the
speaker when he said that I was on that
call and and and and I'm just trying to
understand I get it you guys are
committed to this hr2 which a lot of I
us find offensive and and quite frankly
uh against our our values but
nonetheless I think everybody agrees we
ought to do more at the border to stop
people from coming in uh we got to do
more to to get more
to get these Asylum claims moved forward
quicker and if you don't qualify then
you cannot stay here like I I mean Mr n
talked about the filibus from the Senate
there were some pretty right-wing
Republicans um in the Senate on the
Republican side who I don't think are
pushovers but if there is a bipartisan
deal in the Senate that emerges on this
that can get around a filb bust
isn't it worth at least looking at it
and considering it to see whether or not
there's any Merit at it may not be
everything you want and it may contain
things that I find very very
objectionable uh but before I would rule
it out of order is
unacceptable I mean I'd like to like to
see it and so there's there's this
growing
feeling um by many people on my side
that you guys AR you guys are interested
in the political issue and not in
solving the issue so I I'm I'm trying to
understand on this conversation that the
speaker had that you were on why would
he say that if we don't have a deal yet
well I think you're misinterpreting what
he's saying and certainly out of context
because what speaker Johnson has said
over and over again is that he wants to
work with the Senate Democrats and we
realize we have to work with the Senate
Democrats to get something done but it
just won't be that the house of
Republicans are going to take quote
whatever we're not going to take ucer
promises well maybe you can really
meaningless maybe you because according
to this article according to this GOP
lawmaker what he said in addition to
what I just uh recalled is that that he
would they would back you would back
nothing Le anything less than
Republicans uh secure and uh the Border
act hr2 that it's that or nothing I mean
I is that an accurate um well I think I
think you're totally missing the point
I'm just reading I'm reading I'm reading
from an article that appear there's mult
multiple press reports that this is what
what he said so the deal is I mean I
just want to understand because I mean
you know we we're kind of spinning our
Wheels here trying to find Common Ground
trying to figure out ways to to get to
something that you know could get
through the Senate um and then we can
maybe consider here but why are we
wasting our time if it's it's all or
nothing and and according to multiple
news articles and GOP sources he made it
clear It's All or Nothing am i g yeah
well I'm just yeah I mean is that was
that am I accurate ranking member I
don't think you're accurate in the way
you're portraying this and quite frankly
the first way to to get to a solution of
a problem is to admit there is a problem
and that's the purpose of this
resolution here if if I may there has
been no admission that I have heard even
from the ranking member of the Judiciary
Committee or yourself or any member of
the democratic side of the aisle that
has admitted that there is a a border
crisis Mr with all respect he said it I
don't maybe I'm maybe we're speaking
different langu is Mr of course
I we all I think admit there's a major
problem we have said I said repeatedly
today maybe gentleman can't hear what
I'm
saying is that there are solutions and
the solutions involve adequate funding
for Asylum judges and and for uh um uh
border patrol and so forth and so on
which we've talked about but no one
denies there's a major problem
no I I'm say I mean and that's why I'm
always and I'm a little stunned by your
remarks because many of us have put out
statements about the the situation at
the border the Administration has talked
about the uh the challenges at the
border and U I think and we're trying to
figure out what can we do um and I think
what we're running up against well the
good news is the Senate which I I I'm
not particularly fond of seems to be
actually working in a bipartisan way to
to try to come up with something I don't
know whe at the end of the day whether
there something they come up is with is
something that I can support or you can
support whatever but it's it seems to me
we ought to be open
to to looking at if they can come up
with a
bipartisan um proposal that may not do
everything you
want but actually moves us in a
different direction you know and and
provides more security at the border and
I and so that's why I am deeply deeply
deeply frustrated um by the the
speaker's remarks and I get it um I
understand where some of uh my friends
on the other side side of the owl are
coming from I you know I mean they're
they're this is an issue that's right
for for them to demagogue and they do it
on a regular basis but at the end of the
day if we're really serious about this
um you you know you don't have to agree
on everything to agree on something
something you agree on you get get done
and you move on you keep on doing and I
don't know what the next election is
going to be uh the results are going to
be um you know I I don't know who
controls the house or who controls the
Senate you know or how the uh the race
for the presidency will go uh but the
bottom line is you can't be waiting
around for the next election all the
time to be able to do something and um
you know and I think that there are
Democrats and I hear it all the time you
know that want to do some stuff that I
think some Republicans agree on we just
get that done um and then continue to
fight about the stuff that where we
disagree on anyway that's my I mean I
you know we found our first point of
agreement by the way I'm not fond of the
Senate either so I think we found a
point something maybe we could pass a
bill to you know to say something about
that but uh but in any anyway it it just
frustrating because we we have these
arguments all the time and and it it's
like
there's and I know that there are things
that We can't agree on but yet it's
either all or nothing and I that's why
the speaker's remarks I think are
particularly
discouraging just for a point of
clarification my friend I was on that
call as well and that is to Mr Mor's
Point not an accurate report of what the
speaker said he was given several
hypotheticals that people say well the
deal has this and how anybody can say
that I don't know quite frankly because
nobody knows nobody seen any text yet
and so the remark was well if it's this
and this and this well no I wouldn't
agree to that so it wasn't a I wouldn't
agree to anything or I wouldn't look at
the agreement but some of the reports
coming out from which I think are pretty
irresponsible and they're coming from
both sides quite frankly of the
political Spectrum as to what I you know
I serve with James Lanford obviously the
cater from my state I have a high degree
of confidence and even if he came back
and told me he'd agreed on something
believe me there's things I'm hearing
that I know James Langford would never
agree on so I just I'm actually agreeing
with my friend let's wait and see what
the text is and then I think you're
exactly right we ought to evaluate it on
that basis if we can do something now
but we aren't an automatic rubber stamp
for the United States Senate we were
never designed to be so know may may may
be good enough may not be good enough uh
may require something different but it's
a legislative process and we're pretty
early in it uh to decide we all know and
of course we all know there's lots of
other elements in this agreement it's
not just a border security agreement a
lot of people on my side would feel a
lot more comfortable probably if it were
I actually support the other elements
that would be in that package that we
know more about some of my colleagues
don't fair enough uh but again I just
want to assure my friend speaker did not
say it's this or nothing uh he was
presented with hypotheticals about what
were other people were reading because
of speculation so well basically
certainly I wouldn't accept that or that
or that so let's uh wait and see if they
get to a deal and then I'll join my
friend we'll look at it we might even
find ourselves voting on the same side
no I I I I appreciate that I'm again I'm
just going by news reports I I think
that's fair but I listen to the
conversation so that were related uh to
reporters by a
GOP U member who was the call so and
again I know my friend's never been in a
private conversation that was
misreported someplace that he had to
respond to I think all of us have had
that experience uh on both sides of the
aisle and uh we we'll see what we we'll
see what happens but again I mean I
think at this at this stage of again
this is not a
new issue and it's and and certainly
people this is not a new a new issue
that people have been trying to work on
um but if we can remain open to what
might come out of the Senate and again
it may be something we can can support
maybe that we can't support but as long
as people have an open mind uh I think
that would be probably the most useful
thing we could do I agree very much with
my back thank you very much and I'll go
to my good friend uh Dr Burgess who
actually represents a board of State
thank you and um yeah thank you for
bringing this bringing this to the uh to
the rules
committee um I wasn't serving here in
1986 a bill was C passed was called The
Simpson moli Act Simpson moli pretty
simple principle we've got four or five
million people in the country who are
undocumented we're going to give them
all amnesty and then by golly we will be
serious about securing the Border after
that and here's the problem the amnesty
occurred the security never did and
that's why your constituents and my
constituents are so skeptical of
everything that comes out of this
Administration they've seen him do
nothing but wave the welcome flag and
then ring his hands when he says oh
we've got a real problem
here this is a problem not requiring
immigration reform this is a problem
requiring serious border security and
the administration seems unwilling or
unable to provide that they are
suffering politically mightily because
they are not willing to provide that and
it's time for them to get serious
instead of constantly being at odds with
Governors and they're not just
Republican Governors by the way but
Governors who are having to deal with
this on a Frontline basis because they
are border states instead of always
being at odds to those governors why not
be helpful and look Mr nler a lot of
sympathy for your
mayor um but I got to tell you in the
budget committee a year and a half ago
right before title 42 expired I asked
the Secretary of Health Human Services
what are you doing to provide
information to the people who are
Downstream who are going to be seeing
the vastly increased numbers of people
coming across the border without the
benefit of citizenship what are you
doing to prepare them what are you doing
to prepare their schools their hospitals
their communities for what is coming
their way and what did he tell me he
gave me a non-answer and said well there
intergovernmental ways that this will be
managed well that's BS to be polite
there was no intergovernmental program
there was no warning there were no there
was no willingness to do anything to
alert those communities to what's coming
not to stop the problem from coming but
just to say hey watch out because we're
not protecting the border and this is
what's coming your way as a result
you've got school districts I know in
our state we've got school districts
that are literally overwhelmed with
people new arrivals that they weren't
prepared for No One warned them there
was no uh forew warning to adjust their
tax base so they would be able to deal
with that we know law enforcement is
overwhelmed we hear from sheriffs uh
when we go down and visit the border the
Border sheriffs we'll tell you in very
plain language what they are dealing
with and Mr Manan your analogy about
when you're dealing with a flood you got
to stop the flow first before you can do
anything
else and this Administration refuses to
stop the flow
so my read of what your resolution does
is say look we've got to stop the flow
Mr President if you won't we will and it
has to
happen I was also here in
2010 ranking members left said the
Senate filibuster is what's prevented
any serious immigration reform you know
I was here in 2010 you had a 60 vote
majority in the Senate and although it
wasn't strictly everything that we're
talking about today Mr Durban had his
dreamer act that he wanted to get across
the floor of the senate in a lame duck
session in
2010 you have 60 votes in the Senate but
four Democrats voted against it in fact
three Republicans voted with Mr Durban
four Democrats voted against it so it's
not on it's not Republicans who are
preventing this from happening
when you had 60 votes in the Senate you
couldn't do it either because your
Senators wouldn't vote for it that's
what makes us all so tiresome the
problem is not immigration reform the
problem is security please secure the
border and then we can talk about
whatever else we need to talk about
thank you Mr chairman for letting me
vent on that and I'll yield back General
lady from Pennsylvania is recognized for
any questions she may have so what's
great about this committee is there's
equal opportunity venting um you know it
this resolution starts with a nakedly
political
title um and a lie that the
Administration has embraced open borders
which it has not and it continues with a
number of faults and nakedly political
assertions about the causes of migration
at the border and the government's
response to border
security it fails to recognize the
strides that have been made in reducing
the flow of migrants at the border I
think by over twoth thirds in recent
months and the um increasing seizures of
Sentinel at the
border um what it does make clear is
that this is political that it is not a
legitimate attempt to find solutions to
what is happening at the border um if we
were if the House Republicans were
looking for solutions they would have
embraced the supplemental funding that
the president has requested if house
Republic an were looking for solutions
they would have embraced the
bipartisan um attempts in the Senate to
address the Border issues instead of
declaring that they will be dead on
arrival in the house and
um again it's just clear that this is a
nakedly political exercise House
Republicans are too happy to talk about
the crisis at the border but unwilling
to do anything to address it and in fact
the speaker has been quoted as saying
that nothing will happen on the border
until Trump is back in the white house
where there's another Republican
president so this is a political
exercise I don't think you can expect
any Democrat to vote for this resolution
given the fact that it completely
misstates what's happening and uh takes
as its basic premise an open border
policy which is in fact not the policy
of the Biden Administration so i y
back thank you gentleman from
Pennsylvania to recognize for any
questions he may have for the panel
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate it so
just to put these things in perspective
you know last month was the highest
number of Border encounters ever ever in
our history I mean that's that's the
level where we are right now with that
said judge do you have anything that you
would like to
add uh just to go back real quickly to
what Miss scanland just said um that the
Biden Administration has not embraced
open border
policies I'm I'm struck by the fact that
in a memo by Speaker Johnson back in in
uh Jan on January 4th he laid out 64
different instances and specifically by
date and by action called out the
administration for 64 different things
he has done beginning on day one of the
uh the administration and continuing
through the first week of January 2024
that actually have led to uh the Border
crisis that we're seeing now back in
December uh speaker Johnson sent a
letter December 21st to President Biden
specifically laying out a number of
broad policy agenda items that he should
return to uh I I keep hearing more and
more about this it's a matter of funding
it's a matter of funding it's a matter
of funding if that were true then you
would think that you would have seen a
huge decrease of funding January 20th
2021 because that's when the increase in
The Surge of migration began but what we
know is true is it's not a matter of
funding funding is it's as I said
earlier some of the highest levels even
inflation indexed as we have seen in the
past 40 years but in fact the flow of
illegal immigration has increased and
not just from one country but from
several countries and it's all a matter
of Will and policy of the Biden
Administration that's the admission I
really wish that the other side of the
aisle would would take in this
resolution is to admit that not just
there's a crisis but it's a result of an
emanating from Biden's policies and that
Biden can have the will if he just has
the will to undertake new policies or
return to some policies for made in
Mexico being a at the top of that list
it would fix a lot of the situation on
the border something that we see day
dayto day I yield back thank you judge
Maran I appreciate it that I yield back
thank you very much gentleman of
Colorado recognized for any questions he
may have thank you Mr chairman welcome
ranking member Nadler of course
privilege to serve on your committee and
and Mr Moran welcome to the committee
and understand this is your first
appearance for the rules committee is
that right it is my first appearance
hopefully not my last welcome welcome
thank you for the warm welcome by the
way sure well let's wait till after my
questions baby um you know I appreciate
both of your respective testimonies Mr
Man I guess I want to drill down a
little bit on this point that you've
made very emphatically throughout
today's hearing about funding and you
know ranking member posed this question
to you about border security funding and
you're you adamant that this has nothing
to do with funding that funding is at
its highest levels and that this is not
a funding issue that's your testimony
that is and not to say that there's not
areas to look at where we can increase
funding if if necessary so funding is
issue no no no uh funding is not the
primary issue and that's that's what
I've said funding is not the cause of
what we've seen because funding's at
this all-time high level but when you
drill down specifically certainly there
are areas I think when you look at just
about every area let me ask you a
question about this the budget let me
just finish my statement for a second
every area of the budget is going to be
overly broad I think in some areas and
under inclusive in some areas so there
is always a good faith attempt to look
at every area of the budget to determine
where can we increase where should we
decrease but certainly funding is not
the issue that's being presented and not
the cause of the Border crisis okay so
you've been in Congress for about a year
what was the first bill you introduced
in the Congress the first bill I
introduced was the border security
investment act the border security
investment act I pulled up this bill and
in your release on January 31st of 2023
you say this is a quote most importantly
this legislation will generate funding
for badly needed border security
Investments here's my point the
president has submitted a supplemental
budget proposal to increase border
security Investments and
funding he'd like for the Congress to
work with him collaboratively on
that my sense is that most members of
your conference agreed that funding is
an important priority that we shared
it's just in the last last six months
that now suddenly or I should say the
last four months since the president
submitted his emergency request that it
has nothing to do with funding not
withstanding that I mean you clearly
decided this legislation I'm I'm happy
to take a look at it after this uh
hearing that funding was important that
border security Investments are
important that that's something we ought
to be working on together so I I'm just
struck by the the comments by my
colleagues from the other side of the
aisle and some of the testimony we heard
today this has nothing to do with
funding when uh it's because the
president has made the case that we need
to have increased funding and it seems
to me that it's a a particularly
convenient um excuse in my view to as
the ranking memb said avoid doing
anything about this challenge that I
think we all agree we need to address
but I'm happy to give you an opportunity
to respond yeah and and I I appreciate
the fact that you brought up the board
of security investment act happy to talk
to you about that but again back to the
correlation if if funding was the
primary issue for the cause of the
Border crisis you would see a
correlation between a decrease in
funding and the increase of border secur
of Border uh Crossings illegal border
crossings you're not seeing that I do
think that there is a need for if you
look at my bill technology border agents
and um and wall and this is these are
three specific areas where we can
increase funding as I said there's
overly inclusive areas of the budget uh
and overly Broad and under inclusive I
think this is an area that's under under
included in our budget where we need to
increase that and my board of security
investment act specifically says we need
to take that money and get that money
through remittances not on the backs of
of taxpayers but on remittances they
going back to the the top five countries
of origin for illegal immigration so
that us taxpayers are not bearing any
more financial burden because we're
already seeing an over uh overly
burdensome system on the American
taxpayer to deal with the problems
internally for these illegal crises and
I would just suggest uh sir that I mean
I know when I was starting in Congress
back in 2019 the first bill that I
introduced as a member of Congress meant
a lot to me to my office it was
reflective of the priorities that I
believed uh this Congress ought to be
pursuing and so I I would just say again
I'm struck that the first bill that that
came to mind for you and your team was a
bill to invest in Border technology as
the president wants to do a build to
increase personnel border agents funding
within CBP as President Biden wants to
do and to me that seems like a a place
in which we can potentially find some
common ground but in any event I I'll
conclude just by I suppose reinforcing a
point that the ranking member made with
respect to this particular resolution
because I think you and I will agree
that and it's evidenced by the Plain
language of the resolution this
resolution doesn't actually do anything
I mean it's not there's no provision in
here that changes any
law right correct that's correct right
there's no provision in here that
allocates more funding obviously um it's
a
non-binding statement of opinion for
those members that choose to vote for it
it will do nothing to address the
challenges that we have on our Southern
border and I would just hope that the
Republican conference could put to the
side some of
these efforts that we know are not going
to Bear any real fruit and engage with
us collaboratively on trying to address
the problem because there are many of us
who'd like to do so but it's hard to do
that when we're called back to
Washington to vote on a two-page
resolution condemning the president uh
and that is touted as the Panacea to the
crisis on the southern border I mean I
just I don't think the American people
would would concur in that
assessment happy to give you a chance to
respond if you'd like but no I
appreciate the dialogue I really do and
I and I would appreciate you looking at
my border security investment act I
think it's a substantive provision as
well I was also pleased to uh to
introduce the Visa overstates penalty
act which was part of hr2 and I served
as one of the eight original co-sponsors
to to hr2 and firmly believe we need to
get back to that that's something that I
wish we had more dialogue with
substantively from the Democratic side
to find areas in hr2 that you'd be
willing to support as well because
frankly it is the substantive bill that
needs to get passed what we're trying to
do by this resolution is to ReSound the
alarm and I'd sure like to uh see that
Democrats some Democrats admit that at
least in part if they would just say at
least in part I know I believe it's the
primary cause but at least in part is a
result of the Biden Administration
policies for the past three years I I
would say this uh you know because you
referenced hr2 and there's been so much
emphasis on you know the part of my
colleagues on their side of the aisle
about hr2 you all are very proud of of
that bill and as the ranking member
referen the the call that you all
apparently had with the speaker and you
know various takes on uh what happened
on that call but pretty clear that the
vast majority of your conference refuses
to do anything on immigration uh and
immigration reform border security with
the exception of hr2 that that's
essentially your you know that it's it's
that or nothing right I mean that's the
position that I've certainly heard from
I'm I'm sorry that that's the public
perception but frankly uh the
Republicans uh are doing I think a lot
in a different a lot of different Arenas
to try to move the ball forward and
willing to engage in substantive
discussion but I haven't heard I haven't
heard one say that there's any part of
hr2 that they would support I'd like to
understand if there's portions of hr2
that Democrats on whole would say you
know what we agree with this portion but
so far what I hear is we're just not
going to accept anything from hr2 well I
think as you know obviously we all know
that the Senators are engaged in a
robust debate right now uh in a
negotiation and so we'll have an
opportunity to uh to test this
hypothesis in a few weeks but but anyway
thank you for the exchange appreciate
the time back thank you very much gentle
lady from Minnesota recognized for any
questions she may have for the panel
thank you Mr chair and I just want to
say thank you to uh Mr Moran for
bringing this forward because I think
that this is one of the things the
border is one of the things that I hear
about when I go home and they talk about
it because of the fent andol because of
the public safety issues that it creates
and so we need to make sure that we uh
that we are talking about it and doing
what we can about it and I always
appreciate when Dr Burgess talks so
passionately about the about the Border
issues so and bringing them forward so
thank you to for bringing it and with
that I yield back thank you much General
lady from New Mexico is recognized for
any questions she may have for the panel
thank you Mr chair and as uh the Latina
on the panel as well as the
representative of a border state and I
represent counties that uh border the uh
the Mexico border as well as sadly
counties that B of Texas uh and uh I
will say that I did want to introduce
into the record Mr chairman uh fact
check Asylum Seekers regularly attend
Immigration Court hearings without
objection thank you and there have been
uh Decades of studies that show that
Asylum Seekers regularly do attend court
hearings you know 11year study 15-year
study you know uh shorter term studies
uh Asylum Seekers are serious
uh and they attend their Court hearings
our problem is we don't have enough of
them and I think that that was the point
that representative Nadler was making uh
there was also another fact check that
says that many Asylum Seekers actually
do when you actually look at who
actually applies uh and is moved into
and and uh moves through the process not
those who are rejected at first uh
that's about 32% so when you actually
have the resources to actually do your
Asylum process 32% is a high rate I
think um but what's really problem
problematic for me about this
resolution is what we've been talking
about that it does nothing but continue
a rhetoric which has an incredibly
hateful side to it the
Republican likely Republican need for
president has stated that immigrants are
poisoning the blood of our country
echoing mind com echoing a period in
history when the call to hate somebody
to hate somebody who wasn't like you led
to wordlock 2 led to Nazism and this
concept of saying open Borders or
invasions lead lead to death when people
show up and
murder Mexicans Mexican Americans and
others in Border
towns they lead to incredible rise in
hate crimes lead to rise in
anti-Semitism and they
forget about the benefits that
immigrants actually bring to this
country and undocumented immigrants who
were right now carrying for our elderly
caring for our children picking the food
that you will eat tonight and so I think
that that is part of the problem with a
resolution like this that does nothing
to solve the problem uh but just feeds
into a sense of divisiveness and what I
like about what we are trying to do is
actually look towards a vision where we
become a more inclusive Society where we
honor those who contribute to the
society and where we actually do things
like say the $16 billion dollar that the
president wants that representative
Nadler talked about that actually would
address some of the problems and that
this is not doing any of that and so
with that that is one of my major
problems uh that is actually part of it
all is this divisiveness that this is
really intended I think maybe you didn't
intend it but this divisiveness that
this feeds into
um and with that Mr chairman I'll yield
back thank you very much uh before we go
to uh Mr Langworthy at the end of the
table for his questions I want to make
an observation that relates specifically
to my friend from New York who made an
extra effort to get here if he weren't
here we wouldn't be able to conclude the
hearing tonight so we are all incredibly
grateful for that but as I looked around
this room earlier today or thought about
this room I've spent a lot of the last
weekend like a lot of Americans watching
the NFL playoffs and I have to tell you
it's not been a very good result for
most of us on the rules committee uh if
you're like my friend from Texas or me
from Oklahoma and I assume Mr Roy was
pretty disgusting what what happened to
Dallas or what they did to themselves I
don't to blame anybody I think they have
to step up and take respons
disappointing I'd say and I think of my
friends from Pennsylvania and they had
to watch both the Steelers and the
Eagles go down I think of my friend the
ranking member who's not used to
watching the playoff without the
Patriots in it I can go around the table
now Colorado still you know we'll see
the only guy that had a good night was
Langworthy so when this hearing
concludes I'm going to invite you and
any others who care to attend to the
Chairman's office because I have a
special presentation in honor of your
Buffalo Bills who delivered an
extraordinary performance and Josh Allen
was unbelievable but honestly you guys
were unbelievable across the thing so
thanks for not being hung over and
Delirious and in Buffalo or we'd not be
able to finish this hearing tonight and
but I I'm serious I thought about this I
went out and got the present today it
will honor both you and the Buffalo Bill
can you drink it or smoke it you
certainly can drink it
so with that I want to recognize my good
friend from New York and thank him for
being here well I I am thrilled and and
should we continue to go and and finish
this journey with the Buffalo Bills
we're going to petition uh the state
government to put replace some of the
New York statues in the capital and one
of Josh Allen I think would be the
rightful place at the capital um thank
you Mr chairman um to my colleagues on
the other side of the aisle who who have
alleged that this resolution before us
is meaningless or pointless I'd like to
remind them of the following uh on May
10th of 2023 House Republicans passed
hr2 the secure the Border act to tighten
the Asylum standards criminalize Visa
overstays support our border patrol
agents in short House Republicans pass
legislation to end this crisis at our
Southern Border in in that very month we
had 200,000 illegal alien encounters at
the Southwest border yeah that did not
stop the Biden Administration and Senate
Democrats from falling all over
themselves declaring that legislation
Dead on Arrival and it's also worth
noting that um from what we've heard on
the other side here this afternoon that
House Republicans have included the
highest level ever of SP spending for
border patrol $496 million in this
year's DHS Appropriations bill that's
worth noting as people want to talk
about funding um on May 25th House
Republicans passed the Hal fentanyl act
to support our law enforcement in the
face of a flood of lethal fentanyl
pouring across our borders uh in 2023
alone more than
112,000 Americans mainly young people
many people of color died of overdoses
primarily caused by fentel now we've
seen these numbers on the rise for years
breaking records and destroying
communities but none of this stopped
more than half of house Democrats from
voting no on the halt fentanyl act on
July 19th 2023 house Republicans pass
these schools not shelters act to
prohibit the use of public schools as
shelters for illegal immigrants to
instead keep those schools open for our
children and house Democrats loudly
opposed this bill and openly mocked it
right here in this very room yet just
last week in the opposition of local
residents James Madison High School in
Brooklyn was closed to students students
sent home and put on remote learning to
make room for Sheltering 2,000 illegal
immigrants the students were told to
contact their teachers virtually if they
needed help with that schoolwork haven't
we seen that before and how that works
out uh on November 30th 2023 House
Republicans passed to protecting our
communities from failure to secure the
Border act to ensure that illegal
immigrants aren't crowded into tent
cities on federal lands like they have
on Floyd Bennett Field numerous accounts
from the migrants house there mentioned
how children shivered at night in these
makeshift shelters but house Democrats
voted no on stopping this Asing policy
House Republicans have time and again
pushed for Meaningful Solutions in the
face of an Administration that refuses
to do anything to solve or even
acknowledge the extent of the National
Security and humanitarian crisis that we
have here on our hands we have passed
legislation over the loud opposition uh
of my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle yet time and again we have
been told that these measures are Dead
on Arrival the bottom line is this
President Biden deserves our full
condemnation for his unwillingness to
address the crisis at our borders uh to
stop the flood of illegal immigrants and
lethal drugs into this country Mr
chairman I yeld
back well thank you very much and I want
to thank both our Witnesses for a robust
discussion we uh always expected when Mr
Nadler comes and always a welcome thing
to hear and Mr Mar come see us more
often we appreciate you and your first
appearance here as well our Witnesses
are
excused okay the chair will be in
receipt of a motion from the gentle lady
from Minnesota Miss fishbach thank you
Mr chair I move the committee Grant HR
6914 the pregnant students Rights Act a
closed rule the rule waves All Points of
order against consideration of the bill
the rule provides the amendment in the
nature of a substitute recommended by
the committee on education and the and
Workforce Now printed in the bill shall
be considered as adopted and the bill as
amended shall be considered as read the
rule waves All Points of order against
Provisions in the bill as amended the
rule provides one hour of General debate
equally divided and controlled by the
chair and the ranking minority member of
the committee on education and the
workforce or their respective
designes the rule provides one motion to
recommit the rule further provides for
consideration of HR 6918 the supporting
pregnant and parenting women and
families act under a closed rule the
rule waves All Points of order against
consideration of the bill the rule
provides that an amendment in the nature
of a substitute consisting of the text
of the rules committee print 11
18-20 shall be considered as adopted and
the bill as amended shall be considered
as read the rule waves All Points of
orders against Provisions in the bill as
amended the rule provides one hour of
General debate equally divided and
controlled by the chair and the ranking
minority member of the committee on Ways
and Means or for their respective
designet the rule provides one motion to
recommit the rule further provides for
consideration of hres 957 denouncing the
Biden administration's open border
policies condemning the National
Security and Public Safety crisis along
with the Southwest border and urging
President Biden to end his
administration's open border policies
under a closed rule the rule provides
that upon adoption of this resolution it
shall be in order without intervention
of any point of order to consider HR
957 the rule provides that the
resolution shall be read as considered
as read finally the rule provides one
hour of General debate equally divided
and controlled by the chair and ranking
minority member of the committee on
Judiciary or their respective designet
thank you very much you've now heard the
Motions there any discussion or
Amendment to the
rule here hearing no requests for
further amendments the question is on
the motion to report all those in favor
signify by saying I I those opposed say
no no opinion the chair of the eyes have
it Mr chairman ask for a recorded vote
uh recorded votes been requested the
clerk will call the role Mr Burgess BG I
Mr Burgess I Mr Russian ther Mr Russian
ther I Mr fishbach I miss fishbach I Mr
Massie Mr Norman Mr Roy Mrs Hain Mr
Langworthy I Mr Langworthy I Mr McGovern
no Mr McGovern no Miss scanland no Miss
scanland no Mr nus no Mr nus no Miss
blure Fernandez leer Fernandez no Mr
chairman finally get the cast a decisive
vote
I Mr chairman I cherk will the clerk
will report the total five y four nay
the eyes have it the motion to reports
agreed to accordingly Miss fishbach will
be managing the rule for the majority
and Miss scin for the minority that
would be a good debate uh with that
thank you all for your patience and
thank all of you for taking the time to
get here I know it's very difficult in
many many cases so I appreciate that and
you really were the calvary Mr
Langworthy so thank you for showing up
at the at the last minute I usually as a
Native American don't have a lot of good
things to say about the calvary but
tonight you did it saved us all so thank
you very much and the hearing is
J